[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour it's been my pleasure to
continue to engage with you all in these
conversations and today i'm really
excited to welcome two special guests to
the program to talk about a really
important topic
our first guest is stacy d stewart and
stacy is the president and ceo of the
march of dimes where she has been in
that role since 2017 and she heads the
organization that really is leading the
fight for the health of moms and babies
prior to joining the march of dimes he
was actually the president of the united
way the nation's largest non-profit
organization
and served in that role even prior to
being present in that organization was
also the executive vice president of
community impact leadership and learning
where she developed global partnerships
to advance community impact in more than
40 countries so definitely a person
who's had a lot of impact in a lot of
ways
she's had she's a business veteran who's
had a lot of different senior roles has
a background in finance and investment
banking and continues to serve on lots
of different national boards and in the
washington dc metropolitan area so i'm
thrilled excited and honored to welcome
stacy stewart to the program today
thanks for being here oh thanks for
having me it's a pleasure to be here
definitely looking forward to the
conversation
our next our next guest is angelina
spicer angeline is a comedian social
media influencer and accidental activist
a kunladi graduate of howard
uh angelia is known for her deep and
authentic comedy she's had just
outstanding success has been you know
her her videos and her content has been
viewed more than 90 million times in
more than 45 countries she was a regular
sketch performer on jimmy kimmel live
non-conan has also appeared on ellen on
on the reel
in 2017 angelis angelina also became an
outspoken advocate for maternal mental
health after her own diagnosis and
hospitalization with postpartum
depression but in addition to that she's
also been working with lawmakers in
california and on capitol hill to
implement laws to support early maternal
health it's worked with lots of
different organizations including sinai
hospital
postpartum support international the
world health organization and others and
is currently in production on the push
for permission a feature-length
documentary that uses comedy to empower
women to advocate for themselves and to
normalize postpartum depression so i'm
grateful and honored to welcome angelina
to the program today as well thanks for
being here
thank you for having me
of course my pleasure and as we talked
offline before we even started my my
goal today is to see if i can keep up
with the energy in the room so to speak
i'm really excited and honored though um
but i've been really looking forward to
this for several different reasons which
i've alluded to already um one just
because of the impact and the influence
that both of you had have um as black
women in our society i think that's so
important so important for us to elevate
and to continue to amplify and just the
important topics that you've both been
talking about and the impact you've had
policy wise as well i think that's
really
impressive um the other piece that i
think we'll get to as we go through is
just also your roles as strong black
women and we may be able to dive into
that conversation and talk about the
mixed
reactions to that term itself the pluses
and the minuses that come with that but
i think it's important for us to be able
to acknowledge that here as well um but
as my listeners know i always like to
check in and see how people are doing
overall so with all the roles that you
both have i imagine you have very busy
schedules i just wanted to see how
you're doing today and how you continue
to balance that on a day-to-day basis so
stacy if we could start with you
yeah no it's rare that even someone asks
in a sort of a genuine authentic way and
people always say how you doing and you
just kind of say great and uh it may not
always be great
um so thank you for asking i'm doing i
actually am doing pretty well today i'm
a little tired from watching some
olympics and
i i my my bedtime gets pushed back to
earlier and earlier so if it's past 10
o'clock now i'm like i'm exhausted the
next day which is kind of bad
um but it's actually been great and i
guess um it's interesting that we're
talking about mental health things today
because i think what's been weighing
heavily on my mind with the olympics
are just the incredible issues of
simone biles and naomi osaka and shikari
and all of these black women
who are stellar
like world-class athletes and just the
level of
uh you know if they're feeling the
pressure of day-to-day life just imagine
what the rest of us normal people feel
you know
um but just how how interesting it is
that
the the theme of mental health among
black women athletes is really showing
up in a big way so anyway i know that's
not exactly the topic but it is around
mental health generally yeah um so i
just that's actually been ironically
heavy on my mind but i'm doing great and
everything's good and it's summer so
yeah it's uh it's hot but it's good yeah
glad to hear that i appreciate the way
that you're honest in that company on
that the answer as well and even some of
the topic i mean you're talking about
paying attention to your own sleep too
so we are going to have an episode
coming up just talking about the
importance of sleep and how that
intersects with our mental health and
it's great to hear that you're attentive
to that in your own
life and yeah as you mentioned with with
our black female athletes all the
pieces that are coming to light now
which i think it's really important for
us to be able to talk about um and in
some ways you know we know those things
have been there for a while but we
haven't had the space or the opportunity
to really
shed light on it like we should so i
think it's challenging and and a
struggle for many but also an
opportunity for us to really be
supportive of these athletes and open up
the conversation much more than it's
been in the past so i appreciate you
bringing that in as well
yeah angelia what about you
how are you doing well i am currently on
my hashtag postpartum revolution road
trip
uh
it's my sort of uh missionary work to
take postpartum depression
poorly on the road
across the country
raising awareness and shooting my
documentary about postpartum depression
meeting with lawmakers
and this is my first tour both as a
comedian as an engineer
and
when you ask how am i doing
i'm doing very very very well
i am so overwhelmed
with purpose
right now and overwhelmed with the
support
that
it's being made very clear to me that i
am doing what i was placed here to do
and i'm just very thankful for
god's yes and of my request
and um you know i've been on the road so
i've been eating like crazy
and not sleeping well and managing
schedules and panelists and shows and
everything but today was the first day
that i took time for myself to work out
for the first time since my tour
and i lifted a little weight so i got my
jump rope in
and
i feel great thank you
of course and thanks for sharing that i
mean i think there's so much in what you
shared as well even in the last episode
that we had we were talking about just
that aspect of purpose and how that
impacts
our mental health and it sounds like in
a lot of ways even though this is the
first tour maybe not the first time that
you're in your purse but it's it's a it
sounds like it's a whole nother level
that everything is kind of just tying in
together which i think is great so i
feel good yeah
it's so good
fulfilling and gratifying a lot of ways
follow up briefly though even with your
answer i'm curious because you mentioned
all the business of the tour too so it's
not that what you're doing is stress
free or easy so how are you staying in
that place of where you're able to
answer and say i'm doing really well
amidst
all the scheduling and traveling and is
that is that because you're doing your
purpose are there other things that you
have
put in place that are allowing that to
happen i'm just yeah i'm curious
uh i'm a planner and plans making plans
plans executing my plans are always
sort of my checks and balances
on how i execute things so
that helps my peace of mind going in if
i know that i have a plan
but because this is my first tour
and i'm traveling with a crew of 10
uh camera people and sound people and
we're traveling
in a 40-foot rv
across the country there's a lot of
variables but
because of the women that i'm meeting in
each of these cities and
because of
the openness that lawmakers have to meet
with me
and the yeses that i'm getting you know
i'm taking chances but i'm getting yeses
that meet the
the
the risks
that feels good that's fueling me
because i feel like okay i'm taking a
risk and
it's actually working yeah okay i guess
we're doing this okay so yes i feel
that's how i'm managing yeah that's
great well i mean in a sense too you're
getting that you know not to get too
much into my psychology neuroscience but
that positive reinforcement of taking
that risk and then seeing it come to
fruition and then being willing to take
that next risk and then just having that
that feedback so i think that that's
outstanding in a lot of ways so thank
you
and just to add lip a little bit how'd
the two of you come into contact
together i know you work together in
different ways but how did that story
come about
this question
i'm trying to think how did we i mean i
think it was kind of maybe through
social media well first of all i know
angelina you were connected with march
of dimes out in la anyway
um
and then i was it there just to kind of
through social media and connecting and
then
we got you involved in some stuff and
you were involved with march for moms
which is another organization and we're
connected to them too and
and then you know what was it
it was pretty pandemic so we had dinner
together and we talked about like how we
could do more together
you know i just think in some of these
spaces where a lot of maternal health
people are kind of coming together
especially around black maternal health
we're all meeting new people and
connecting with people and
forming alliances and partnerships and
you know we were
when angelina first started talking
about
the postpartum revolution and like this
whole
um effort um to get this comedy special
going
i don't think a lot of people really
believed in it or felt like it was
really important and she really stayed
on with this vision i think i chipped in
some money personally very small
and then it's led to us kind of being in
partnership with her on this whole tour
thing and being a you know so anyway it
just i think they're just a lot of um
you know i mean that's how it should
really develop is that like you start to
meet people expand you grow um
and you know she's been such a
passionate sort of
and a very interesting voice in the
space of maternal health that it made a
lot of sense for us to figure out how we
could
be more supportive of her work and uh
really partner so we could reach more
women for sure yeah but is that right am
i missing i'm missing something aren't i
i don't know no you're not stacy i
i meet people on social media all the
time
i don't always meet ceos onsen
when i met a black woman ceo from march
of dimes i was like well let me find out
so i i wasn't gonna say it stacy that's
why i allowed you you'd answer the
question first because i wasn't sure
what we were actually gonna say
what
yes stacy and i met on social media he
said in my dms but not in
and i was so honored
that she replied and that i felt a
connection and you know i came to uh the
march for moms and i
usually participate every year and speak
at their rally on the national mall and
participate in their advocacy day but
stacy was like we have to go to dinner i
want to take you to dinner
we had dinner and we put on lipstick we
took our selfies and i was just like i
felt so connected but also left feeling
like i want to be
in in partnership with march of dimes
because of lucy so i've been ringing the
bells and advocating i mean even when
we're not technically in partnership
like we are right now on the hashtag
postpartum revolution road trip i make
sure at all of my events i have march of
dimes resources for my moms and for
other folks that come to my events but
aren't even expecting to be lectured
about postpartum depression i don't know
if you take a march of dimes pamphlet
here's some resources for you i make
sure
that uh that i lean into the work that
they're doing
uh with all of my events and all of my
work that i do yeah
yeah i think that speaks to both you
know the authenticity that both of you
have
just in your interactions with each
other and just how you come across it
seems like you really
vibed off of that when you first
interacted to and first met and have
that common cause too so it's really
exciting to hear i mean all the
important work that you're doing you
both allude to some of the pushback
though that you got early on and i would
or people not believing in the mission
i'm just curious if you could elaborate
on why that is especially in this day
and age
when there seems to be more conversation
about but there's always still that
pushback
yeah do you think that's coming from
well i'll start angelina i think
so there's push back at a number of
different things i mean i think first of
all
you know in the country we weren't even
having these conversations around
maternal health generally
physical mental any kind of
um you know women because i think a lot
of it is that women generally are not
prioritized in this country the way we
should be
and then certainly pregnant women are
not it's appalling though
that in a in a
you know society like ours we wouldn't
be putting
as much priority on the lives of moms
and babies i mean it's just striking
um and you know we obviously we talk a
lot about the fact that you know we are
considered the most dangerous developed
nation in the world in which to give
birth now how in the u.s do we find that
at any level acceptable right
and
and so i think it's just been
you know i honestly i think what's
happening is that the storytelling is
beginning to break through i mean
angelina telling her story
uh beyonce telling her story serena
telling her story or something like
charles johnson telling his story about
kira who died you know in a hospital in
l.a
you know um
once those stories storytelling we know
is very powerful so march of dimes can
be ringing the bell all day and we have
been talking about premature birth for a
long time but when those actu when those
stories start to break through it
changes the whole narrative it changes
the
uh public awareness it and sort of
embeds itself in everyday conversation
and people's consciousness in a way that
organizations like mine can't always do
and so
you know now we've gotten to a point
where i don't i still don't think we're
paying enough attention to i still don't
think we're prioritizing in the way that
it should be and dealing with it with
the sense of urgency but i definitely
can say that we're at a different level
of conversation about it and a lot of a
different level of attentiveness
uh and i'm saying that from the
perspective of washington dc where i
think policymakers are trying to are
starting to look at this very
differently so it just takes time you
know these things don't always happen
overnight but we're we certainly have
made a lot of progress in my short time
here at the march times and which is
four and a half years um
angelina what do you think
i realize that i have a unique voice
in that
i am yes a storyteller but i'm also a
volatile comedian okay
so that's where the pushback for me came
uh with people
particularly organizations
not in the comedic world i mean i've
gotten pushed back on both sides both
in the
on the organizational side and on the
hollywood side okay
so
on and i say organizational i mean like
non-profits policies hospitals brands
etc
on that side you know there's pushback
or hesitancy because i am a comedian and
i can say
whatever it is
i want and usually comics go off the
rails sometimes you know they can go off
the rails and say crazy things etc
so i'm a liability i can be perceived as
a liability on that side um you know for
example i have been fundraising for my
the push for permission documentary film
that i'm currently
crowdsourcing and
you know putting together and producing
and i went to a hospital
and we had an amazing pitch meeting we
showed them all of our assets all of the
production companies and networks that
are interested in our film and they're
like well we don't know what you're
gonna say
so wow
there was hesitancy from that and you
know i'm an artist first i don't want to
be censored but i also realize their
obligation to their board and and those
that keep the the the organization
functioning so that's okay
what troubles me the most i would say is
that
hollywood
has
pushed back
in a way
that
reinforces the idea that
you know
you don't matter unless you're a
celebrity
don't matter
um
because
quote no one knows who you are
um
and
you know i've had a number of production
companies and networks
tell me well
well why do we care that you have
postpartum depression
we could ask gwyneth paltrow
we could ask
vegan or somebody yeah exactly and
regardless of
my messaging my messaging is very
different from a beyonce definitely from
a gwyneth paltrow because
and i have a comedic voice so there's
going to be some levity there's going to
be humor there's going to be
accessibility to my messaging
but in hollywood it doesn't matter
because quote unquote no one knows who
you are
so
i that's why i have just been so hyper
focused on my small donors and knocking
on doors and i'm just going to make the
film make the project that i want to see
in the world
that's not triggering that moms can see
themselves in
and you know and i've gained
partnerships from organizations along
the way hollywood is slow going but it
doesn't matter because i know that
there's an audience for my work and i
know that it's there's value in it
whether or not i'm a celebrity yeah you
know
wow well i appreciate you sharing that
level of canada too because i mean so
you know speaking as a complete
hollywood outsider just hearing you talk
about that
just makes it sound like that the there
isn't an emphasis on the message
never
there's
on the money and i get it
listen which is why i'm like i will
raise my own money
get my own message out there
because i know that there's an audience
for it and it's slow going whatever it
is but
we're doing it so yeah emotion is
happening and moms are reaching out to
me in droves on social media
and organizations you know the
university of nairobi reached out i
started working with who university of
south africa the israeli government
reached out and wants me to come and do
trainings and with doulas and
hollywood is not the end-all be-all
my mission
is bigger
than the nose right it's only for the
moms who are in distress
the moms to be so i'm clear on my
audience yeah probably be late let them
be late that's all right yeah and the
way you've you've talked about that too
it sounds like people are able to relate
and that might be an advantage of the
non-hollywood route anyway that people
can
see you for who you are
not have to worry about
stature not to say you're not
accomplished but just say okay this is
someone i can relate to they've gone
through it i can connect to them and i
think there's just such a power
that comes with that i agree and you
know and i joke and i say you know
nobody knows who i am so people care
more you know
and i have less to lose so i can talk
about you know my broken lady parts and
how much i hated my husband after i had
my daughter because i'm not serena
williams you know if serena says that
she has
endor's going to break the internet
right
and then that overshadows her
the message the message is the message
nobody knows me so girl you gonna get
the whole the whole
my business
and that makes it better more accessible
but i also think that you know so let's
get to the message right which is that
i mean how many people really do want to
talk about mental health in a really
sincere way anyway
um how many people actually want to hear
about it in a way that um
you know is not
uncomfortable for them i mean it's it's
just um
you know we we have a
we are so
um
uncapable right now or incapable of
really
acknowledging
the degree to which we completely under
fund under resource
um
you know the mental health challenges
that that so many people in this country
face i mean we're talking about
women who are pregnant or who give birth
and who are new moms
but frankly i mean would where we
wouldn't even have an opioid crisis to
the extent that we do if we didn't have
a lot of people struggling with their
mental health um
um and
and um and and this is not new right
like we've been dealing with this for a
long time
um and i think it's just really
something that um
we are trying to
get
this message i mean that's so to the
question about pushback i mean i think a
big reason why we do see the pushback is
that
people are just really really struggling
with even how to
acknowledge these issues and talk about
them and then frankly deal with them
um and i do think that's why it's so
important that people
you know even if um
angelina is whatever level of celebrity
she wants to call herself
she still has a huge following she has a
huge voice
and i do think that it makes a big
difference when people
who are visible who are in the public
side make themselves vulnerable
to talk about these things because it
helps all of us
when i go to the hill if it helps me if
a member of congress has seen something
on social media or a movie or a
documentary like i
then it makes it that much easier when
we had to say yeah well you know about
that now go ahead and give like however
many millions of dollars we need
to make sure that we have a 24-hour
mental health hotline to from for new
moms or to make sure we have the
resources to make sure we have medicaid
coverage for women who are seeking those
kinds of supports and need their
coverage paid for right that it makes it
that much easier so it's all of these
individual efforts that collectively
roll up to something where we actually
eventually have a movement that actually
moves a needle and then and gets changed
to a place where we can get help to the
people that really need it yeah that's
so well said and i'm so so glad that
you're able to harness the power of all
those components even when you're on the
hill because i think that makes a huge
difference i want to pick up on one of
the things that you mentioned too just
in terms of us not knowing how to really
engage and talk about it
because even as you mentioned i'm sure
you all know the stats i mean even
before kovid just thinking about mental
health challenges in this country one in
five who are struggling with mental
health in some shape or form so when you
break that down most of us either
personally ourselves or family members
or friends know somebody who's
struggling in some shape or form with
mental health but we still don't know
how to engage with it always and we
still don't fully acknowledge it so i'm
even thinking about as you're talking
about on the hill i would imagine most
of people in those rooms
are in some shape or form touched by
mental health challenges but does that
mean that we engage in it or not and so
i'm curious as to how you know as an
organization and angelia as you how how
you've tried to address that piece of it
too because a lot of times it's not far
from where people live in a metaphorical
sense but in some ways there's this
aspect of denial and not engaging yes
yeah i i'll just i mean one of the
things i just think it's um
it's not only everyday people and
policymakers are not engaged we even
have healthcare providers that don't
even know how to ask these questions we
have you know one in five women who are
pregnant who never get asked or screened
for depression
like angelina um
and um and uh even even more that don't
get asked um you know during whether or
not they're uh having any kinds of
um signs or symptoms of depression in in
the postpartum phase
um
when we look at maternal deaths overall
about one in nine maternal deaths are
actually attributed to
issues around maternal health
um so these issues are really life and
death and so part of what we've been
saying is we need to we need to make
sure that everyone is aware
of
where these issues show up we need to
have everyone prepared to see certain
warning signs or symptoms
that could help someone get referred to
help the help they need
but we have to have our own health care
professionals and the health and
hospitals and healthcare providers
absolutely focus on this and not willing
to turn a blind eye to
anxiety and stress or just like chalking
it up as oh yeah well that's normal
there's always a little postpartum
depression well
why is why should even if that exists
and we do see it
what onus or what responsibility do you
have as a healthcare professional to
screen for it to refer women to the
kinds of support that they may need
ask the question and what we're really
saying is
some of those healthcare professionals
aren't even the ob gyns where women may
not be even going back in for their
follow-up visits after the baby is born
sometimes it's the pediatricians who
need to be and we're really glad
pediatricians have this on their radar
screen increasingly so
could be screening for it during well
child visits and things like that so
it's really kind of raising awareness
and making it more of a
ongoing way of practicing medicine right
but but knowing that our health is not
determined by what happens in the in the
doctor's office mostly
we have to have family members community
members um
clergy and others willing to talk about
these issues and help our fellow
you know especially new moms
um if they see
if they are you know showing signs that
they're struggling and make it uh make
it available for them to acknowledge
that they may be struggling and then
find that help i think angelina's story
around that is really powerful about
you know how she eventually got to the
help that she needed but thank god that
she was able to be in the hands of a
care provider who really paid attention
to her listen to her and found her the
care that she needed and recognized it
that she actually needed it because
you know we we would want to have seen a
worse outcome for angelina or any other
mother as a result of just giving birth
to their child right i mean
it's it's
no woman should have to struggle in that
way yeah so important needs to be
elevated all the way around as you said
society-wise healthcare-wise i love how
you're you know tied in all different
aspects holistically clergy community
members all we need to be on the same
page together to really make sure the
conversation doesn't get left
angie i wonder if you'd be able to to
share a little bit about what you
learned in your journey too and how
that's informing the work that you're
doing now even as you're on tour bernie
i'm
that's true
the journey with you with your uh was
your postpartum after after the birth of
your your child oh my gosh well i
i feel like i should give an abbreviated
version of what happened yeah if you're
willing that'd be great no i mean i tell
my business for a living so
let's have at it um
yeah so i
am married i like to tell people that
because um they think that you know
black women don't get married but i'm
married i actually planned my daughter
uh that's another stereotype and stigma
married
uh planned pregnancy educated middle
class um and again i'm a planner so i
planned for this life but i didn't plan
on developing postpartum depression
um
i
had a doctor who i felt like
really minimized my anxiety during my
pregnancy and it was a developing
anxiety because i was marked high risk
towards the end
and i didn't recognize it as as anxiety
because i didn't know
what i was really experiencing in it
and i didn't know that it had a name
so uh
you know and there was so much
preparation for the birth of my daughter
that
i wasn't really put i didn't feel like i
was put on the right track to be
prepared
for once she actually got here
so when i pushed her out
there's a picture of me that's going to
be in the film where i just looked
afraid
i looked scared and that was the first
time they laid her on me it was the
first time i looked into her eyes and i
was overwhelmed by
my new responsibilities
her provider and
protector
i just i was scared and then you know
compound that with the sleepless nights
uh with the
aching body parts um
the diapers
the you know my relationship with my
husband was tested like all
relationships are
after you have children you know i just
felt like everyone lied to me i felt
like my doctors lied by not preparing me
for what was to come
i felt like my friends my peers
no one was honest about what their
bodies had gone through
i just felt like everyone was kind of
muscling through
and and forgetting
getting to tell me so when i felt like i
was having
experiencing depressive thoughts and
intrusive thoughts which i didn't know
was a thing
you know luckily i was under the care of
a therapist
for years i had seen my therapist before
i um
like six years before i decided to have
my daughter and so she knew my baseline
we had a good relationship and she was
suggesting things to me over the months
that i was literally trying to climb
myself out
and one day at eight months postpartum i
went to her office and she recommended
that i check into a psychiatric facility
and
most people would be afraid
i was excited to go
i was relieved
it was time it was time to feel better i
wanted to feel better i just didn't know
how
and my therapist gave me permission
to
go to this place
and get be taken care of and you know
all my meals were provided it was it was
a great
time out
that i didn't know that i could get as a
new mom
and you know and since then i've just
really been advocating for new moms new
families new parents
and even mom even women who are yet to
become parents
i feel like
we need to be honest with them about
what this is really going to look like
yeah because not what you think it's
going to look like it's not going to be
horrible it's not bad but it's not what
you're going what you think it's going
to look like
so and to your former point about uh the
pandemic
and
the stressors of the pandemic i know
for myself
the lockdown the quarantine
made me and homeschooling made me feel
triggered
i felt extremely
panicked and worried and
i felt incapable
all over again incapable of mothering
and incapable of balancing and
you know
my husband and i decided after a few
months that it was time for us to send
our daughter back to daycare because i
just wasn't able to manage but
that was the best decision for our
family at the time and i needed the
freedom to be able to say i'm drowning i
can't do it
um but there were a lot of moms who felt
you know the same symptoms of having
postpartum depression during endemic
yeah
yeah there's a lot there and i
appreciate you sharing that story as
well i mean so many pieces
that you're paying it forward in a sense
too because even as you were talking to
your story you know talking about how
you didn't have the language to know
exactly
what you were going through even as
someone who had already been in therapy
so i think that's a that's a really
critical point too to make sure that
people as you've already done are having
those conversations ahead of time
and know what to expect
and how to move through it
because even as i mean both both sides
are working simultaneously even as you
all are doing trying to make sure the
healthcare workers are providing that
information
having those who are going through it
have that information as well and so
when the misses still happen
to be able to tackle it from both sides
in a sense i think is
is hugely important and then everything
you mentioned i'll go ahead stacy well
one thing i want to say about what
angelina said is that i think that idea
that when you
so for a lot of i mean i'll just speak
to my own experience because it's i mean
i didn't go through the level of
postpartum depression that angelina
experienced but i do think that there is
something about becoming a new mother
that
is incredibly shocking and like
um
i don't think anyone is ever
i i can't imagine that anyone is i mean
if you're well prepared for motherhood
as soon as it hits like god bless you
right because
i think it is such an out of b you're
like literally having an out about
experience
and it's um i i can remember feeling
like the same thing that angelina said
which was like they lied to me because
you know everyone says oh motherhood is
so beautiful and wonderful and you're
going to love it and honestly
the first
few days weeks are
so incredibly hard
it is a hard and and this is for someone
like someone like me who didn't have to
deal with as many of the mental health
challenges
it didn't matter it was incredibly
difficult and
and i was someone who had already like i
had my kids really late i mean my first
daughter was born when i was 38
and i by then i had been out in the
workplace work world and i've done all
these things in my career
and so to be home for four months at
home by myself
with my child who cannot speak to me i
cannot have a cogent conversation with
this little child yeah
and then it was like
i i was like i don't think i'll survive
this this is so hard so i think and then
of course all of your physiological
changes
are complicating how you process all
this all the lack of sleep trying to eat
healthy healthy healthy eat it all first
of all
i mean it's just like all sort of
combined with each other into like a
whole
and then you know and then you get for a
lot of women you get past that first
three months or first six months
whatever and things start to kind of
they're still difficult you're not
getting still not getting sleep but it
starts to kind of settle in but i just
think
we've got to do a different a better job
helping
women prepare for motherhood in a very
realistic way so that things like
angelina where you don't get feel like
you get hit by two by four when the baby
comes you actually are prepared to say
okay this is going to be the hardest
thing you've ever done in your life and
it's going to start
second one when that comes
in the hospital when that baby's on your
chest you're like welcome to the
beginning
yeah i'm gonna engage the plan
absolutely
right
exactly yes
i think that's so important that you're
verbalizing and vocalizing that too so
people aren't surprised even though i'm
sure i mean there's no way in the
obvious yeah right there's no way no way
to prepare completely 100 to have the
expectation that you won't be able to
prepare completely
yeah and that there are some things that
you can do
to set yourself up for some level of
success and for me
had i known the information i would have
planned differently i would have hired a
postpartum doula right i would have you
know i would have made sure that my
husband
you know banked vacation days so that he
stayed home
you know longer with me
honestly i would have taken a second job
to pay for child care because that's
what i needed relief so going in knowing
what you can handle and what resources
you can call on yeah whatever it takes
you know you will you can
you can at least engage the plan
so that you're not so overwhelmed and so
disengaged from your reality it's also
like i mean this is where we look at the
us and compare ourselves to other
countries right
in other countries you do have midwives
and
and um you know why don't we have a
whole
uh program um where everyone
irrespective of income or anything can
access a
a doula
during pregnancy and childbirth and even
postpartum why don't we have the
resources in this country to pay for
that and make that available to any
woman that may need it why don't we have
paid family leave in this country which
is pretty standard in other countries
right why don't we provide um you know
nursing and home visit visitation the
way you know it exists in other
countries you know why don't we have
universal coverage so if women are
experiencing you know mental health
challenges they have resources like
there are so many levels of where we
have underinvested in our human capital
that show up in
all of the things that angelina talks
about in her own story that we see in
the statistics around maternal and
infant health
and frankly i'm not saying writing a
check and putting more money in these
things actually eliminates the problem
because then we have the other issue
especially as it relates to black and
brown women
where just the basic uh effects of
racism and discrimination impact us on a
daily basis
and that skews the outcomes as well
disproportionately relative to women
that look like me and angelina but
having said that
a lot of this and when you look at ways
in which to address anti-racism and bias
in this country
you know policy solutions are at the
core of what we can start to do to
reverse some of the impacts of what
we've been experiencing over generations
and that we're still living with and
frankly to be in a country this wealthy
and and to not being provided the basic
bare minimum
for for women um as they're bringing a
new life in the world it's just simply
unacceptable i mean it just and it's and
it's why i think both of us are so
passionate around like we can't live in
this world and society
uh and and tolerate this and we
shouldn't tolerate for any for any for
any length of time yeah very well said
and i think there's the support the
support isn't there i think that's what
angelia was referring to and what you're
articulating as well just it's so
critical but
so lacking
we need the policy support you know
that's a huge component of work i do
also it's like
you know moms in california i worked on
legislation there to help with expanding
screenings
and also training physicians because as
stacy mentioned you know
doctors and labor and delivery nurses
and folks in in l d just in general may
not know how to implement these
trainings or these screenings so there
needs to be resources and time that's
invested to make sure that they're able
to now do
this work and also when red flags are
raised
where do we send these moms you know i
was
reaching out to my ob gyn
at
you know two weeks after my eight week
checkup like hey i'm i need more
resources i need help i need medication
i need a therapist and she was just kind
of like a deer in headlights oh boy no
yeah and then she prescribed it the the
medication to me but never followed up
so
you know there's there's more work to be
done especially on the policy level you
know so that's a part of the reason why
i did the postpartum revolution trip
was so that we could advocate for the
same for moms to have the same exact
treatment in california all over the
country there's no reason why moms in
north dakota or in tennessee where their
reproductive rights are in jeopardy and
you know are constantly up for debate
and on the ballot box but you there's no
reinforcement or there's no help once
the babies are here for mom
yeah okay it's one of the big reasons
why you know one of the things that we
advocate for
you know when we're pushing for the
federal level is is mom to us which is a
whole bunch of legislative actions that
would address
all these things from maternal mental
health to you know all the issues of
reshaping the perinatal workforce so we
can have more doulas and midwives and
you know a whole range of other other
aspects you know the other thing that
the march dumps we've done is like
introduced a lot of programs to provide
additional levels of support so for
example we've
and we've been trans trans um
transferred to a virtual
program around supportive pregnancy care
really group prenatal care which
really allows women to go through their
prenatal care obviously checking in with
their physician
but also checking in with other moms
that are pregnant along with them so
that you can have an honest conversation
with other women that might be
experiencing some of the same things and
then continuing that kind of group care
into the postpartum phase because just
when i mean when the baby you know when
the baby comes just beginning of your
problems right
now you have a whole set of other issues
to deal with and you still need that
support you know postpartum as well you
know and the last thing i have to say
too is going back to this issue of
how the healthcare system needs to
acknowledge the unique challenges that
black and brown women face
um and how we know that the healthcare
system does not listen to us and respond
to us in the ways that we need
we introduced an implicit bias training
program for healthcare professionals
about two years ago we trained 15 000
healthcare professionals to recognize
their implicit bias and now we have a
new component which starts to go through
different scenarios so you can play out
what scenarios look like to see where
your implicit bias actually does show up
in your day-to-day interactions with
your patients so
and not just doctors and nurses it's
really even like um the front desk
receptionist who like gives you a side
eye when you show your medicaid card
right which is like all of a sudden now
i don't want to come back to this clinic
because i don't feel
i don't feel valued i don't i feel like
i feel diminished right
and that happens far too often and um
and so there are all these things we
need but we we just have to do this at
scale if we're going to see
these kinds of outcomes improve in our
lifetime yeah
wow that's really encouraging to hear
all the steps that you all have taken
across the board because it's
it's a huge undertaking when you're
dealing with a system that's already
at so many levels even as you mentioned
from receptionists all the way up
there's going to be so many biases along
the way and each step along the way is
going to have an impact so
yes
even as i know the time is going fast
which is which is unfortunate in that
sense but i did want to kind of tie back
to this idea of the strong black woman
because you've talked about you know the
things that you've done on the policy
side and things like that but i'm also
curious just how as you're working in
different communities and in communities
of color in particular how people are
embracing of this this need for support
along the way or is there still this
tension of
well as strong black when we don't need
to tap into this i'm just curious how
that how is that conversation
going i'm gonna go to angelina first
since i see you smiling as i'm as i'm
making those comments
well stacy has seen my comedy special
that we are touring around the country
with i have a whole section
that addresses the strong black woman
because that myth
we've got to flip that on its head
strength is asking for help
strength is saving the money so that you
can pay the help
guilt-free
strength is employing people to make
your life easier strength is enjoying
luxury as black women we are because we
don't have a history
of indulging in in these kinds of things
we don't have
when we are suddenly able to we kind of
had this guilt or we you know
or this shame and judgment from family
from friends
there's a whole thing behind it but i
you know i always tell people
strength is really truly in asking
and
allowing people to help you
um i
my problem was was that i didn't know
what to ask for he helped and that's
where the preparation for me would have
come in had i known what to expect i
would have been prepared with what to
ask for
but then also
allowing people to help you
i allowed my therapist to help me that
was her job i allowed my mom to help me
but i didn't allow my cousins and my
other supportive family members to help
until i was in crisis
and that's what i i know you know moving
forward that i tell
black women and mothers mothers in
general we feel like we should be able
to do it all
you know carry a baby in the front one
in the back puts one in the stroller you
know answer work emails on a call on a
zoom all at the same mama we ain't got
to do all that no ma'am no ma'am no
ma'am we need to have a seat but the
strong black woman
the strong black woman asks for help so
let's start asking for help and
receiving the help yeah that's so good
distraught you know
um
there's no question black women have
been
have had to be
incredibly resilient
over
many many generations and
um
you know it's funny because i go back to
the um
the book about leaning in remember
sheryl sandberg and i i remember
thinking how absurd
you know
the idea to have the choice to lean and
should i lean in or not it's like well
black women haven't actually had that
choice right
like we don't have a choice but to lean
in like like our families are dependent
on it's like you know the world falls
apart if we fall apart like it's
actually
that's how it is right and so
um
so
i think we have to i think we can be
both proud of
that we
have proven time and time again that we
are always ready and willing to rise the
challenge and to do what is necessary
but we have to also acknowledge that
that has traditionally come at an
extraordinary cost
to our health
and to our both mental health and
physical health there was research done
on on weathering the idea of weathering
which is
kind of how our health uh deteriorates
over time because of just the lived
experience of being a black woman in
this country and that weathering then
has an impact on our birth on birth
outcomes for our own babies but that
stress and anxiety layered on layered
year after year generation after
generation
actually deteriorates our lives and our
physical health and
that is not okay
it is not okay for us to live in a sp
a way where we're constantly on
adrenaline constantly on fight or flight
because that eventually wears us down to
the point where we see all these chronic
health conditions i mean i've i've told
the story long many stories
angelia's heard me say this about my own
experience of growing up with my dad it
was a physician
and him having all these patients that
have stress and anxiety but what it what
but what they also had was chronic
obesity hypertension
diabetes
but he often mostly diagnosed them with
anxiety
first
like and this was in the 60s 50s 60s 70s
like he even saw and recognized and
although he
i don't know that there was as much
research out at that time but he was
actually documenting
the connection between stress and
anxiety and these other chronic health
conditions and i carried that thought i
have carried that thought with me my
entire life until i walked into the to
the offices of the marshaps became the
president ceo and started to see the
actual research
the to
the the evidence around this yeah so
here here we are today all all we got
all we can do right now is to say
one we have got to
make sure that women especially women of
color
find a place and a space in this country
and i'm and i call out the united states
in particular although
we could say this is a global thing but
in this particular country we have a
unique experience
of having to still address the legacy
and of slavery that has and we're still
feeling the effects of that today today
and what we what we ought to do in this
generation that we are the leaders of
right now is to call attention to it and
to try to do as much as we can to
reverse the impact so that ava who is
angelina's daughter or my daughters
maddie and savannah do not have to
continue to live in a world in which
they are continuing to be
they're subjected
to the same level of kind of
oppressiveness that so many black and
brown women have to face in this country
that shouldn't we should we have to do
everything we can fortunately we're
we're standing on the shoulders of many
black women
and brown women who fought very hard it
is our job to continue that fight and to
elevate that fight elevate it do even
more you know
so important and you're right in terms
of the legacy and just the need to move
things forward i mean it's even
encouraging to hear encouraging and
sobering to hear the story about your
father as well documenting those things
at that time because as you mentioned
that wasn't highly documented i mean
there's more evidence for that now
clearly and just the detrimental effects
of racism on mental health and so many
other aspects of our health and
especially for black women so i'm deeply
appreciative to what you're both doing
in that way and to wrap up i just want
to also just hear what gives you hope in
this moment
with all the challenges that clearly
still need to be addressed um in so many
ways around mom health mom and baby
health mom's mental health what gives
you hope moving forward
well i'll start it what gives me hope
is
seeing
the impact of the work
being the impact of
of seeing the impact
of
you know an idea that i had or you know
to take a risk and share the fact that i
was admitted to a psychiatric facility
on social media
and to see moms
open up to me
and
ask me to help them check into a
psychiatric facility and facilitate that
that gives me hope wow it gives me hope
you know
to see my daughter ava and to see that
she
at six years old has the
language not quite the understanding
just yet but she's the language of the
postpartum revolution
postpartum depression
helping moms helping families helping
babies that gives me hope um there's
still a lot more work to do
you know on the postpartum revolution
road trip i recently met with uh
congresswoman uh lisa blunt rochester
who is uh she's working on the mom to
bus and she is she's awesome
a dynamite woman
like stacy
we i had an immediate connection with
i also
had a very great policy meeting with
congresswoman yvette clark
uh on the hill
and both women are super supportive
of
my mission and my goal to help
formulate legislation to support new
moms and to work with uh
those of us who worked on the bill in
california the bills on california to
make federal legislation that gives me
hope the fact that these women
are willing to meet with me an average
woman who as hollywood says no one knows
who you are
but these women took the time to hear me
and to
meet with me and their policy directors
so that we can help moms who are in
similar situations but also help moms
avoid similar situations yeah we hope
yeah yeah
so i think what gives me hope is just
the momentum um you know again just
seeing how we're having different kind
of conversations where
you know we weren't having these
conversations before um
you know i can see minds
being open to
really understanding these issues i can
see people not being so quick to
diminish
you know if a woman has a problem with
her pregnancy it must be her fault it's
not her fault right and people are
starting to say wait a minute maybe
there's something more systemically
wrong here
um
and that's and that's where in
washington i mean that's in both sides
of the aisle i see republicans i mean
when i see republican members of
congress
who are like moved literally
authentically moved to tears when they
hear a story like from charles johnson
about losing his wife kyra
you know hours after their second child
was born
i mean these are these are human issues
and
we're living in a time when
there's a lot that doesn't make sense
and there's a lot of craziness that goes
on and there's a lot of things that
people don't believe a lot of facts
people just don't are willing to accept
and a lot of people that other people
are willing to dismiss
as if their concerns or issues don't
matter and what i'm finding is that at
least on the issue of mom and baby
health there is
there is the ability to find some common
ground
we were at an event last week with two
republican members of congress and two
democratic members and one of them said
i love
um coming to a march of dimes event
because i think this is the one place
where republicans and democrats can
agree and they weren't talking about
this march of times they're really
talking about the bigger issues that
we're working on
but that is encouraging and inspiring to
me so i think we just got to keep that
momentum going right um yeah
so again i'm deeply appreciative of both
of you for the work that you're doing
also for both of you taking time to come
on this podcast i know this is going to
be something that our listeners are
going to really resonate with and he
plays thank you for doing this too
you're doing a great job we appreciate
it
it gives me hope that you as a black man
are giving the sisters the space
right at
the least but but the awareness of your
audience to value
what to value these issues i'm just like
come on that gives me hope black man i
don't know
and here it says a yale professor and
researcher a man of faith and a sports
and hip-hop fan
is our host how about that
balance bring it full circle
i'm deeply appreciative and again just
to see what you all are doing
as black women so so encouraging the
least i can do to amplify it because
your voices are being heard need to be
heard more so i'm playing my part i'm in
the background this time so
deeply appreciate both of you thanks so
much for being here
check out things at march of dimes
angelina spicer.com more information
postpartum revolution
definitely important work and appreciate
what you're both doing thanks so much
thank you
[Music]
you